there are countless amazing movies made
every year throughout the US but have
you ever wondered which ones were filmed
in your state today we're listing the
best movies filmed in every state
Alabama stands in for upstate New York
in get out a gripping thriller that was
even nominated for Best Picture
into the wild tells the true story of
Christopher McCandless who froze to
death in the Alaskan wilderness the film
is beautiful and deeply sad
with a standout performance by Nicolas
Cage raising Arizona is funny chaotic
and dripping with style
Mudd is a unique coming-of-age story of
a drifter living on an island in the
Mississippi River it's an interesting
portrait of America
[Music]
there are too many great movies shot in
California to choose so I pick
Terminator 2 because it's amazing
Quentin Tarantino's eighth film the
hateful eight is like a three-hour
bottle episode set in a small cabin
against the Colorado wilderness it keeps
you on your toes the whole time so what
happened to your horse we've got old
another earth is a very unique
independent film and the whole premise
of a literal other earth floating in the
sky plays second fiddle to a very
down-to-earth human drama
who doesn't love a Robin Williams movie
in Dead Poets Society he plays an
eccentric private schoolteacher who
instructs his pupils to seize the day
it's a tragic and delightful film
captain my captain
sit down mr. Anderson
this slice-of-life story in a live in
motel in Florida is sad and hopeful all
at once and the performances of the lead
children and Willem Dafoe are astounding
earning Dafoe and Oscar nomination week
of the summer and there's already been a
dead fish in the pool
[Music]
Atlanta is front and center and baby
driver an Edgar Wright directed
adrenaline ride with a kick-ass
soundtrack clever script and some
reaction
[Applause]
genetically engineered dinosaurs eating
people on an island set to a John
Williams score what more could you ask
for
Jurassic Park is an absolute blast and
the fictional setting of easily Nublar
is brought to life by Hawaii's natural
beauty nobody expected Napoleon Dynamite
when it came out in 2004 the humor is
quirky in the truest sense of the word
and John heater's mannerisms as Napoleon
make for endless memorable moments
perfectly capturing the ideal day of
playing hooky Ferris Bueller's Chicago
high jinks and the very real story of
uncertainty of friendships at the end of
high school make for one of the best
films of the 80s
[Music]
Samwise Gamgee sorry sean astin plays
rudy a dyslexic man with dreams of
playing football for Notre Dame it's a
simple heartwarming true story
[Music]
honestly the voice is pretty creepy but
the film certainly isn't it's a touching
story of father and son and a love for
baseball based on Truman Capote's novel
of the same name this crime film is
notable for fantastic cinematography and
being a great page to screen adaptation
I'd like to apologize but who to
to be fair only one of the three races
in the film was shot in Kentucky but
that doesn't take away the fact that
Seabiscuit is a great movie it was
nominated for seven Oscars and probably
would have won one if it hadn't been up
against the most awarded film of all
time Lord of the Rings Return of the
King
like any Tarantino film Django is
profane violent and full of blood but
it's also exciting hilarious and has
some standout performances if it's a
Stephen King adaptation expect it to be
set in Maine this horror film continues
to be very frightening even 30 years
later with the dead one of the first
examples of a found footage film The
Blair Witch projects horror comes more
from what it doesn't show than from what
it shows the fact that the camera swings
wildly around and you never get to see
the eponymous which makes the film both
more infuriating and more chilling
Rian Johnson's subversion of the murder
mystery genre was an unexpected hit of
2019 its ensemble cast is incredible the
dialogue is quick and every detail is
meticulously planned I've never been to
a wheel rating oh you think it'd be like
a game show but think of a community
theater production of a tax return
Eminem's feature film debut takes
inspiration from his own life
it showed that Eminem was a talented
actor and was a great showcase for his
music the music alone makes Purple Reign
worth a watch as does the charisma of
its star Prince the whole thing was shot
in and around Minneapolis
you can feel the atmosphere of oh
brother where art thou and the
award-winning soundtrack pushes along
this fantastic Depression era satire of
Homer's Odyssey
if you want to feel stressed but in the
good kind of way you get when you watch
a great movie I picture cracking or
lovely skull watch gone girl the entire
film is beyond tense thanks to David
Fincher's talented direction and the
uncomfortably good performance of
Rosamund Pike I've never heard of this
film until recently but thoroughly
enjoyed watching Jeff Bridges and Clint
Eastwood commit crimes throughout
Montana I was a little too much for them
to handle yeah hey send me one of these
boarding schools Jack Nicholson's
excellent performances Warren Schmidt
really is at the heart of this
character-driven comedy that was filmed
almost entirely in Nebraska my name is
Warren R Schmidt and I am your new
foster father the hangover is one of
those comedy movies that everyone talked
about for years after its release it's a
roller coaster of action with Tigers
Mike Tyson drugs and a missing friend
set against the backdrop of the Vegas
strip it's also pretty funny
[Music]
another classic Robin Williams movie
Jumanji is the story of a board game
come to life it's never not fun it was
filmed in and around Keene New Hampshire
hey garden state is a charming movie
about entering adulthood
it's creatively directed by Zach Braff
and has a grammy-winning soundtrack this
is your one opportunity to do something
that no one has ever done before and
that no one will copy again throughout
human existence and and if nothing else
you'll be remembered as it's the one guy
who ever did this it's one thing it's
obvious that Logan isn't your average
superhero movie it's darker more
emotionally driven and much more violent
than anything else in the genre and that
makes it stand out as a great superhero
movie but also as an excellent film in
general hey I got you here that's all I
signed up for even get back to money
today see Spike Lee's do the right thing
captures the feeling of urban culture in
Brooklyn New York in a way that very few
other movies achieve the settings
characters and the style of the shots
and editing make for a unique and
fascinating depiction of the
neighborhood it's like to sign a
petition to boycott Sal's famous
pizzeria
man I ain't boycotting Jackie string T's
head mother
[Music]
we'll be Goldberg's debut performance
among a cast of incredibly talented
actors is reason enough to watch the
color purple
it's a great depiction of issues black
women faced in the early 20th century
while the film bounces back and forth
between North Dakota and Minnesota the
titular city is in North Dakota
it has murderers comedy and accents for
days sitting here an hour he's peed
three times already
oh I'm sure sorry Shep told me 8:30 it
was a mixup I guess
[Music]
the Russo brothers managed to hide a
crime thriller in a superhero movie and
a pretty good one at that something you
may not have noticed is that throughout
the film Ohio stands in for various
spots in Washington DC The Outsiders was
one of the first books I read to really
make me feel something and the film
adaptation is a fantastic retelling of
the story it's a solid coming-of-age
drama that was shot almost entirely in
Tulsa
[Music]
what's not to love about a group of kids
on a quest for pirate treasure this 80s
classic is always reliable fun The
Silence of the Lambs is one of the
tensest movies ever made the threat of
both Buffalo Bill and Hannibal Lecter
seem all too real and Anthony Hopkins
portrayal of Lecter is downright
terrifying
good evening Clarice Wes Anderson's
distinctive tastes are on full display
and moonrise kingdom
it's a colorful movie that's full of
heart remember this isn't just a search
party it's a chance to do some
first-class scouting Forrest Gump is an
American classic it's inspiring and
simply a joy to watch and much of the
film was shot in South Carolina on its
release Dances with Wolves was applauded
for its careful portrayal of the Sioux
people it's a long epic film with a
deeply engaging story
[Music]
it's hard to top the performance of
Michael Clarke Duncan and the Green Mile
an emotionally gripping film about
inmates on death row with a supernatural
twist is doing such as much of the film
was shot in and around the old Tennessee
State Prison on the day of my judgement
when I stand before God and he asks me
why did I did I kill one of his true
Manos what am I going to say then it was
my job Javier Bardem is scary at least
in No Country for Old Men a modern day
Western thriller that lives and breathes
Texas the unnerving plot keeps you on
the edge of your seat for the whole two
hours call it alright page then well
done
the prologue that starts off 2:30
Indiana Jones movie takes place in the
iconic Arches National Park in Utah it's
here that we get a taste of Indy's
escapades as a young man the film as a
whole is also in my opinion the most fun
of the whole series
while the interiors were shot in a
soundstage
most of the exteriors for Beetlejuice
were shot in Corinth Vermont it's a wild
movie with Michael Keaton at his best as
the ghost beetlejuice and it's
absolutely packed with Tim Burton's
unique sense of style in this dramatic
biography of the 16th President Daniel
day-lewis brings Abraham Lincoln to life
with an incredible performance the movie
is worth watching for the production
design alone seamlessly transporting you
back to an 1800s America there's a
reason Nora Ephron kept casting Tom
Hanks and Meg Ryan they're two of the
most charming actors to ever grace the
screen though they barely meet in this
movie their chemistry is palpable in a
way that only Efrain seems capable of
creating breathe in and out all day long
and after a while I won't have to remind
myself to get out of bed super 8 feels a
lot like an 80s blockbuster in the vein
of ET or The Goonies a lovable group of
friends trying to make a movie lie at
the heart of this exciting sci-fi
trailer
John Dillinger is one of the most famous
bank robbers of all time
Public Enemies is an exciting depiction
of Dillinger's story and was filmed in
several locations in and around
Milwaukee Devil's Tower in Wyoming plays
a central role in the plot of Close
Encounters of the Third Kind it's an
optimistic film about humanity's place
in the cosmos and if you watch it you
won't be able to get those five notes
out of your head doot doot doot doot
doot what did you think of our picks let
us know what you think the best movie
filmed in your state was down below in
the comments
[Music]
you